hey welcome to neural Nets in JavaScript
with brain j/s I am super excited to
teach you this course the goal is to
give you a practical introduction to
problem solving with neural networks
what you're going to be learning in this
course propagation both forward and
backward layers neurons training error
what feed-forward neural networks are
what recurrent neural networks are and a
whole lot more we're gonna build as or
gate a counter a basic math Network an
image recognizer
a sentiment analyzer and a children's
book creator and now we're gonna do it
as with 17 lectures what we're gonna
focus on practice over theory what that
means is you are gonna get your hands
dirty but more than that you're gonna
walk away knowing the ideas behind
neural networks there's as well a bunch
of interactive challenges along the way
and that brings me to our use of scrim
ba' scrim B is a fantastic platform for
learning and at any point during the
entire lecture you can stop me it won't
hurt my feelings you can just introduce
brand new script and you can press
command + s if you're on Mac or ctrl + s
if you're on Linux or Windows and it
will execute exactly your code that is
super important throughout this course
as well I'm going to make regular
reference to the console which is
directly below here so if you see some
numbers go down there like I'll go ahead
and test that right now
0.05 just appeared that's super
important anytime I start talking about
if the neural net was good because it
had a low error rate or if the neural
net was bad because it had a high error
rate just look down there and that will
give you a little bit of reference as to
what we're doing so let's get started
this is going to be awesome
this is our very first neuron that this
is gonna be awesome so the first problem
that we're gonna tackle is called
exclusive-or and you can do some
research on it if you like but more or
less this is what happens you have
inputs that are the same they result in
a zero output when they differ it
results in a one there's always two
inputs there's always one output so
let's take this very simple comment and
let's translate it into something that
the neural net or rather the JavaScript
can understand let's have a variable
we're going to call it training beta and
there's our very simple variable that
represents all of our training data um
let's go ahead and import brain j s
brain j asses i'm just gonna grab a link
that imports it from a CDN content
delivery network at that and next we
want to instantiate a new instance of
brain and we do that const press a net
equals new brain neural network and down
here we're going to say net dot train
and we're going to give it our training
data and now at line 16 by the time we
get there the the net will have
understood what our inputs and outputs
are and so we can here console log out
net dot run one of our inputs so let's
choose the first one
that's a give it our way
hidden layers three we'll get more into
hidden layers later and now we're going
to go ahead and get run and now we have
an output that's so awesome
now the reason that this number here is
not zero is because we're using a neural
net and it's very hard for them to speak
specifically zero and one they can speak
close to that so that's exactly what we
want is a number close to zero which is
0.05 now here's a challenge for you go
ahead and get the next outputs console
logged out I'm just kind of play around
with their values and and see how the
net operates
in our last tutorial we talked about how
to build a neural net a very simple one
to solve exclusive-or and in this one
we're going to discuss how it did it
so the neural net has different stages
you'll notice I use two different
methods here the first one is trained
and the other ones run now in train we
do something called Ford propagation and
back propagation those terms may seem
scary at first but they're actually
quite simple in fact we're going to
reduce their complexity down to
something that even a child can
understand you'll take a look at my
slides here forward propagation and back
propagation we have a ball we're gonna
take a ball and we're going to throw it
at a goal now when we do that we're
going to make a prediction as to how far
the ball needs to go how much energy to
put behind it the pathway of the ball
etc I want you to go ahead and pause the
video here and to think about the
different steps that happen when you
throw a ball at a goal the first step is
prediction and in prediction we're going
to think about how we're gonna throw the
ball where it needs to land how much
power we need to put behind it that
first step and with my SPR showing off
that we did not go far enough with the
ball this step is for propagation we
ourselves are making a prediction from
that that prediction we can see how far
we were off from the actual goal we can
measure that and that that step of
measuring that is back propagation now
the next thing that we want to do is
make a determination as to what we're
going to do next
that is our sec
step of backpropagation that is our
learning step and you know how the story
goes we throw the ball again it goes too
far we measure that or make another
prediction we throw the ball again third
time's the charm
that illustrates this very first method
and everything that goes on inside the
net the next stage is running our net
now in running our net we no longer have
to measure how far we are from the goal
we already know and because of that
there is no need to back propagate so
that step goes away now throughout this
entire training of the neural net the
net is measuring and that measurement is
referred to as error check this out if
we go to our net during its training we
can actually enable something really
interesting we're going to give it a log
function we're going to console.log
error and we're going to have our log
period set to 200 intervals so now we
can actually see the error how far off
the net was and you can see for a time
some of these errors may go down or may
go up but eventually the net catches on
and it starts to accelerate its ability
to learn until the error rate starts to
drop to a ridiculously low number not
zero though until training is completed
and once training is completed there's
no need to continue training as we
discussed we can then just forward
propagate
our last tutorial we talked about how
neural networks learn using for
propagation and back propagation in this
tutorial we're going to understand more
the structure of the programmatic neural
net neural nets are actually quite
simple they are composed of a function
that receive inputs as an argument and
produce outputs if we think of our
neural net and that's very simplistic
way then really we can reduce the
complexity of it down to one of the
simplest functions that you can write
pause the video here and just look at
the structure now we're going to talk
about how the network initiates did you
think about when you were first born
likely you you didn't know very much
over time though you begin to know more
and more the neural net begins with a
bunch of random values so everything
that affects the outputs is just random
at first you may ask yourself why and
the reason is because mathematically
we've proven that is an effective way to
start off with knowledge the knowledge
is very random at first we don't know
the idea it's not zero and it's not one
it's somewhere in between over time we
can shape that random data so that it
finally becomes where we store what's
going on inside of the neural net each
neuron is quite literally math dot
random go ahead and pause the video here
and get comfortable with the idea that
the net starts out with random data next
I want to talk about activation a really
popular and effective activation
function that's used nowadays is called
Ray Lu
ray Lu looks come like this if we were
to put it inside of a function the
function would quite literally look like
this
that is our activation
called Rayleigh now activation functions
are measured in backpropagation using
what is called their derivative I'll go
ahead and put a link here and our bonus
material - I'll go ahead and post some
links that take you to array Lu and its
derivative are used in brain
now last tutorial we talked about the
structure of a neural net and in this
one we're going to be talking about
layers take a look at my illustration
this is a neuron that each circle
represents a neuron the arrows represent
a bit of math stacked circles are layers
and so here we have what are called
input layers that's this first one this
next layer would be a hidden layer it's
composed of two neurons the next is
another hidden layer composed of two
neurons and the last is called an output
layer now in brain the input layers and
output layers are configured for you
kind of automatically however our hidden
layers can be configured by us our first
neural net was composed of two input
neurons one hidden layer that had three
neurons and an output layer that had one
neuron just as our illustration has two
neurons for the input layer two hidden
layers the first having two neurons the
second having two neurons and the last
one having two neurons what's
interesting about hidden layers is
that's really where the majority of
their storage is if you likened it to a
human the hidden layers are where the
ideas are you may run into a scenario
where your neural net isn't learning
I'll go ahead and recreate that here I'm
going to change the hidden layers from a
single hidden layer with three neurons
to that of one and I'm going to log out
training data
watch what happens we hit 20,000
iterations without fully understanding
the problem and how to solve it now we
can easily fix that by changing our
hidden layers to a single hidden layer
of three neurons you can see we're able
to Train in a short amount of time 4800
iterations we can as well have more than
one hidden layer our illustration has
two hidden layers we could mimic this
exact configuration two hidden layers
followed by two hidden layers and this
way
action though but more hidden layers
that you add the longer it takes for
their neural net to Train let's try it
see we hit 20,000 iterations without
actually fully training there is no hard
and fast rules when it comes to hidden
layers this would be an invitation to
experiment something I have seen though
is to treat the hidden layers sort of
like a funnel so if you had for example
20 inputs you could have 15 hidden
layers followed by 10 hidden layers
followed by 2 output layers that's just
an example though and many problems take
on different configurations switching
gears for a moment take a look back at
her illustration you remember that we
have these arrows and I said these
arrows represent a bit of math and a
feed-forward neural net that math can be
described as this we have our input
weights times our inputs plus biases
activated now this is simple math but
the implications of it are huge pause
here and just think about how simple
that is and let it sink into your brain
this tutorial series is really about the
practical application of neural nets but
if you're curious like me you can take a
look here see how brain uses this math
has another bonus take a look at the
additional options that are available
for brain neural nets can be widely
configured to solve many different
problems all it takes is experimentation
time and enthusiasm
up till now we've concentrated on the
basics of how neural networks and we've
used a raise for our training data but
in this tutorial we're going to be
talking about sending different shaped
data into a neural net now to illustrate
what I mean by that let's take a look at
my slides here we have an array now it's
a very simple array but it's an array
and what makes arrays incredibly useful
is we can reference the values by index
for example they raise index of 0 gives
us 0.3 the array index of 1 gives us the
value 0.1 arrays are useful in neural
nets because they represent a collection
generally of the same type of values and
we can use the index to look up those
values if we look at an array beside a
neural net we can see each neuron
associates meaning with each of the
arrays indexes now when dealing with a
collection of the same type of value
this is perfect but what about when our
data isn't in the form of an array what
about for example objects it just so
happens that brain j/s was built for
this type of practical use and we are
going to build a neural net that uses
objects for training to get us started
I've included the browser version of
brain jeaious here in the index.html
file next let's define what our training
data will look like our input will be an
object that is going to have the
properties red green and blue and our
output will have properties light
neutral and dark it just so happens I
have some training data I'll go ahead
and paste it in and you can see our
colors and brightnesses what's really
useful with brain j/s is you don't have
to define all the properties you can but
you don't have to when they're missing
it simply uses a zero in their place so
in this first object we see that red is
missing well red here will just simply
be zero you can see a similar practice
on the brightnesses let's go ahead and
turn these two different arrays of
objects into our training data so we're
going to define cost training data
equals an array now we're going to
iterate over the brightnesses and colors
and build up our training data so for
we'll say let I equals 0 I is less than
colors dot length I plus plus now you
can use a for each or even a map
training data dot push we're gonna give
it an object each one of our training
sets is an object and that training set
will have an input and that input will
be of colors and our output will be from
the brightnesses and those indexes are
equivalent next we'll define our neural
net so const net equals new green dot
neural net work and we're going to give
this hidden layers I have a single layer
with three neurons and next
can basically just train our neural net
so net dogs train and we're gonna give
it me training data rather than logging
out what is happening inside the neural
net let's just get our stats what
happens at the very end and we'll go
ahead and log those to the console now
let's see what we get cool
12 in iterations it learned it fairly
quickly and let's see actually what we
neuron that outputs so next dot run and
a value of read 0.9 of read and we'll
log those values out let's see what we
get very cool so you can see in the
training set we did not include dark
neutral and light and every single one
of the brightnesses however brain is
smart enough to combine those together
and it gives us with red being a 0.9
that red is dark now as a bonus like
it's spelled on this correctly there we
go what if we had to invert the problem
what I mean by that is what if we are
for example asking our neural net for
colors rather than classifying their
brightness in this scenario pause it
here and think about how you would
accomplish this so by inverting the
problem our inputs within the light
neutral and dark and our output would be
a color red green or blue for us to flip
the values let's define our training
data again this will be constant
training data and we are going to for
but I equals 0 I equal those colors not
lengths we're going to take the inverted
training data and push objects to it
that are just like prior our input and
output but we are going to change the
input to accept brightnesses and our
output to accept colors so that's our
training data next let's define a in
inverted net those new grain dot neural
neural network the same hidden layers
and let's training inverted that's equal
inverted net got trained inverted
training data we'll go ahead and train
on this cool let's log out the stats as
stats but we can see it actually didn't
do a great job at learning the problem
but that isn't the point of this
exercise it's really just to understand
the neural net from a different vantage
point when you flip a neural net like
this you're kind of generating values
that can be really useful in predictions
in this tutorial we're going to get a
bit more adventurous and push the
boundaries of what you can do with a
neural net but doing so in a safe and
easy manner but to help us understand
take a look at my slides in our previous
tutorials we used numbers directly in
the neural net numbers are just one of
the types that exists in JavaScript and
in other languages on JavaScript is
fairly simple in its types in fact we
have only boolean numbers objects
strings null and undefined it would be
nice if we could feed these other types
of values into the neural net
so that it can understand context better
and solve different and seemingly more
complex problems so are we doomed then
do they just speak numbers previously we
used an object with a neural net and we
did so using its properties defined with
numbers but the principle of assigning a
value to a neuron will provide us the
answer for our neural net to speak more
than just numbers on the question in
your mind is probably how let me
illustrate in a way that a child would
understand this is a light switch it is
off now if you were to ask a child to
turn the light switch on they of course
would but I wouldn't just happen like
that
what happened more like my son does he
sees that it is off and he becomes
excited and he's taking gymnastics and
so he will use that to his advantage
she'll perform some amazing gymnastic
maneuver over to the light switch
turning it on seeing that it's on that
he just did something very useful he'll
let out a cheer and do some gymnastic
moves off in a way celebrating that he
was a useful kid and that he has the
ability to flip switches this ability to
understand both off and on has huge
implications now our computers they
speak binary that's just ones and zeroes
so it's very very similar language to
the neural net we could use this same
practice we could say that zero is off
and one is on now we sort of did this
previously with objects via their
property name but we fed the inputs
directly into the neural net in this
case we assign a neuron to a specific
value that we are training towards
either the input or the output and when
that input our output neuron fires we
basically just assign that value as 1
otherwise it's 0 so just like our on and
off we're taking these values like a
boolean our null value or a string etc
and we're simply assigning it to the
input so here my potentially null value
is being fired upon so it's a value of 1
my string 1 is as well the other values
are not and as for output the net is
gonna try to learn those values just as
before and so really the implications
here are that we can suggest about any
value into a neural net so long as that
value is represented by a neuron ok
let's go ahead and get coding and then
this will all make sense first off in
our index.html file I have included the
browser version of brain j/s next we are
going to get some data that we're
eventually going to use to Train on this
initial data is an object with property
names of restaurants whose values are
what day we can eat free with kids and
our objective is to find a way to get
these string values representatives ones
and zeros into the neural net and what
we're going to do is give the neural net
a day of the week and it's going to tell
us where to go on that day of the week
so that we can eat free with our kids
now pause it here for a moment and think
how you would accomplish this using that
light switch analogy next
go ahead and plan how we're going to
input our training data into the neural
net so if we are going to use the day of
the week as the question we're going to
ask our neural net that will be our
input so our input is going to be a day
of the week so Monday Tuesday Wed miss
day etc our output is going to be the
restaurant name so restaurant to you so
that is our input and output for our
neural net now next we're going to go
ahead and build up our training data so
let's go ahead and build that using a
Const that's going to be training data
that's going to be an array and to put
data into the training data from our
restaurants we'll need to iterate over
our restaurants so for let grunt name in
restaurants and the day of the week is
the value they're in so Const a week
equals restaurants restaurant name all
right so we've got our day of the week
and now our restaurant and our training
data we're gonna push a value to it that
has our inputs and outputs an hour input
it's going to be this is where the
rubber meets the road so to speak it's
gonna be our day of the week we're gonna
sign that a value of one I'll just think
about how simple that is if you need to
pause that please do so but think about
how simple what we just did is we are
giving an input to the neural net of a
day of the week assigned by its value of
one now all the other days of the week
because of the way that brain Jay
built are going to initially be 0 so
only this day of the week will be 1 next
let's go ahead and assign our output
that's going to be a sense restaurant
name and we have just built our training
data if you need a moment to pause and
think about what we've just done please
do so but it's a very simple principle
the principle of represented values next
let's go ahead and define our neural net
that'll be in const next new green dot
neural network and we're gonna give it
the same hidden layers as before single
hidden layer with three neurons and all
that is left to do is trained on our
training data so we'll do const stats
equals net dot trained training data and
then we'll console.log our stats out all
right
are you ready we go look at that under
2,000 aerations the neural net has
deciphered what day of the week to eat
for free with our kids that's nice but
let's look at what comes out of the
neural net let's all dot log net got run
we're gonna say Monday see what it says
this is where it gets kind of
interesting all of the restaurants are
included with our result we just have a
likelihood associated to each one of
those restaurants but really what we
want is to put a string in and to get a
string from our neuron that we're going
to do that next if you can pause it just
think about how you might be able to do
that okay so we're going to create a
function and its name is restaurant or
day it's gonna get a day of week we're
going to use that value with our neural
nets so net dot run day of a week this
is going to be our result and from that
result
we'll have this collection of
restaurants with the likelihood that we
should eat there and the highest
likelihood will be the correct
prediction for of a given day so what
we're going to do is start out with a
highest value and as well the highest
to iterate over our results so for left
breast and result and then we're gonna
say if the result a strong name it's
higher than our highest value and we're
going to set our highest value to that
value namely Awards we're going to save
the highest restaurant name plus
restaurant theme and from here we'll
just return the highest restaurant name
and so from this we're going to accept a
day of the week
a stream we're going to put that into
the neural net the Nerlens going to give
us its predictions those predictions are
a list of restaurants we're going to
iterate over those restaurants and then
we're going to save the highest one and
we're going to return the highest one
well we'll go ahead and log the results
out so this is restaurant for day we're
going to say Monday and we'll test all
out there heard his brilliant yellow
Corral perfect now let's let's add the
rest of the days of the week so Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday Sunday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday all right
there you go
we've got all the restaurants for the
given days of the week so now we've got
a string in and string out before our
neural net next as a bonus try and flip
this logic the other way so that you are
inputting a restaurant name and you are
getting out a day of the week I'll leave
you to it
in this tutorial we're going to learn
how to count and although that sounds
kind of like an easy task
at first it actually is a little bit
difficult but when we use the right
tools it becomes easy take a look at my
slides and this will give us a
background on where to get started this
is exclusive or our first problem that
we solved each of the empty squares is a
zero and each of the black squares is a
one now let's take a look at a different
input one that may be a little bit more
tricky it's hard to kind of see what
this particular input means so let's
rearrange it so that it's easier for us
humans you can see this is a for now
both of these inputs illustrate
something that may have occurred to you
already and that is that they have width
and height or length now width and
height is just sort of another way of
looking at length width and height don't
really change neural nets they are
constant but in computers there are some
rules that can be bent and others that
can be broken and we'll start
illustrating that now by going to the
movies on your trip to the movies you're
going to bring your best friend along
and they're of course thrilled at going
to the movies with you because it's the
latest and greatest movie that you've
been looking forward to and everything
is going fantastic and in fact it's the
cliffhanger scene right there at the
middle but all of a sudden the screen
goes black why why did this happen the
screen went black it was right as I was
expecting something to happen next
why were they expecting something to
happen next well it's because they they
built up a memory of what was happening
up to that point that's important think
about that just for a moment we'll come
back to it back to our non-playing movie
your best friend looks at you and
they're of course thrilled that they're
at the movies but are saddened that the
movie will not continue to play and then
all of a sudden it starts to play again
and there
as thrilled as could be and the movie
ends just as you had hoped so that is
our illustration of the movies now if
you think back about where we paused in
the movie every frame of the movie was
the same height and width every frame no
frame was different in size if you think
about that over time though a frame
being one part of a movie one frozen
image of the movie each frame has that
constant size that there are hardly any
movies that are the same duration they
all have different times that they play
out that duration that's depth that's
our frames plural that's mini frames
that is really important with neural
nets the depth the frames how long the
movie is and what happens on each frame
and what leads to the next one that
gives us a context as to what is
happening in the movie that's the same
with neural nets this context in a
neural net recurs it's something that
happens over and over again something
that has to in a sense repeat this
terminology and neural nets is called
recurrent now that sounds like a very
complex word recurrent oh no what are we
going to do next
it's actually quite simple and to
illustrate that let's go simple let's
let's go to something that even a child
can understand one now at it's very
simplest if I go to a child and I say
one likely the child will not understand
what I'm talking about unless we've
trained on that in previous sessions so
one to a to a child is is foreign and
it's the same with a neural net I don't
know what you mean by one that's
essentially what the neural net will say
however as soon as we start giving it
context it being a neural net or it
being a child that they can start to
decipher what we are trying to ask from
I'll continue we talk to our child we
say 1 2 3 4 and we pause what do you
think the child will reply with likely a
response would be 5 now this is where
recurrent happens with neural Nets
recurrence is like taking each of these
states 1 2 3 & 4 and sort of putting
them together in a sense adding them
together into a counter pool
and that pole says you know the most
likely thing they're looking for is
probably and then out comes a 5 that is
depth it's the same as our movie it's
the same as being able to see each frame
and that depth happens over time if the
movie played out of sequence if the
frames were shuffled in a sense likely
we get very little out of the movie now
this context is sort of a observer that
that looks at each of these steps and
can guess what comes next that context
that depth that time that recurrence
I'll refer to a very similar concept
that depth that time that context is all
dynamic they're all the same width and
height or even the same length but
they're not of the same depth because we
can feed in more than one and the
context is dynamic too in a sense that
we can say one two and ask for what's
next and I'll say three or we can say
three four what's next and it will give
us a five or we can even reverse it and
say five four three two what's next and
it'll give us a one that's how dynamic
that recurrent concept is in our neural
net the ability to sort of take in those
multiple frames
that's called a recurrent neural net and
when this simplest form the feeding of
for example numbers is like stepping
through time or a time step and as I
said in this too
we're gonna learn how to count okay now
to get started let's go ahead and
include the browser version of brain j/s
so we'll add that here our training data
it's going to have two different
outcomes one is going to count from 1 to
5 and the next one is going to count
from 5 to 1
we'll define our training data manually
that'll be a Const called training data
and it is going to be an array and in
that array we'll have two arrays the
first one will be 1 2 3 4 & 5 and the
next one will be 5 4 3 2 & 1
that's it that's our entire training
data next we'll define our neural net
constant net equals now this is a new
namespace in brain new brain dot
recurrent dot long short-term memory
or L STM time step now to train the
neural net we'll give it our training
data using the Train method net dot
train training data and let's see what
actually comes out of the neural net
while we're training it by logging we're
going to give it a log function
let's go ahead and see what happens all
right it trained really fast very cool
but let's remove the logging now that we
know that it can train and let's see
actually what comes out of the neural
net so console dot log net dot run and
we're going to give it part of one of
the arrays that we defined in the
beginning so one two three four and
that's it for the first one and we'll do
the same for the second one right
because we want to as well count down
from five not run and we'll do five four
three and two all right let's see what
comes out there we go awesome we got
exactly what we wanted and that is how
you count using an ermine in our first
one we gave it an array of one two three
and four expecting a five and that's
what we got for point nine eight and in
the second one we sent in a five four
three two and we're expecting a one just
like we have a peon training data and we
got a one point zero zero five so that's
really exactly what we wanted now as a
bonus try adding another training array
that counts from ten to five or even
from five to ten
in our last tutorial we used a long
short-term memory time step neural
network to count that's a mouthful and
in this tutorial we're going to use that
same sort of net and we're going to work
up to predicting stock market data so
let's take a look at how our data is
shaped first our raw data is going to be
where all of our values live no this
isn't yet training data we're going to
turn it into that our values are going
to be from an object and that object is
going to have properties open high low
and close each one of those are numbers
now let's take a look at our raw data
for a moment now if you look for example
at the open property you'll see it's
quite a bit larger than numbers that
we've used previously which were from 0
to 1 or 0 to 10 now the values repeat
and you'll see that open high and low
and close follow a similar pattern what
we want to do though because the neural
net was instantiated with values between
0 and 1 and that is sort of a language
that the neural net speaks if we just
send these values into the neural net
it's going to take it quite a bit of
time to sort of ramp up its
understanding of these larger numbers if
you can imagine it's like walking up to
somebody who has only ever heard
whispers and then just yelling at them
it would be first awful really and
secondly it would just be loud it
wouldn't be what they were used to what
we want to do is make it easy for the
neural net to interpret this data and
this is a very common practice so let's
start out by writing a function and this
function is going to normalize our data
but since normalize is the most friendly
term let's just call it scale down
that's our function name and scale down
is going to accept a single object and
we're going to call that a step so
that's a step in time now the same
object that we have coming in we just
want to turn down those values and so
we're going to return an object and that
object will have open and for the time
being we'll go ahead and return stepped
up open or define it rather with step
open and it's same for hi etc
and that is our scale down function
however we're not normalizing anything
yet and since if we go over to our
training data once more and we look at
these values one of the lowest ones that
we can come to is this value 138 or so
so what we're gonna do to get these
values easily into the neural net
it's simply divide by that value so 138
there and that's our normalized function
quite simple and to prove that it works
let's go ahead and console.log it out
it's a constant log scale down we'll
just grab the first item and our raw
data yeah and we can see the values are
fairly close to between 1 and 0 now if
you're positive just for a moment think
about how we go the other way
scaling up or as they say DD normalizing
ok so now what we're going to do before
we do any machine learning we're
actually going to write the inverse of
this function which would be the
denormalize or in practical terms the
scale-up function so function scale-up
and it's going to take a step and we're
going to return that same sort of
signature that same sort of data but
rather than dividing by 138 the exact
inverse of dividing is multiplied so we
will multiply by 138 and now we have our
scale-up function referred to normally
as d normalize so normalize brings it
down denormalize brings it up and to
test them both side by side we'll go
ahead and console that log
scale up it'll look kind of funny scale
down and I will have our raw data and
we'll send that in and what do we get
there we go
our scaled up and scaled down functions
we're going to use these in our next
tournament but this is a very common
practice across neural nets in general
not just for current neural nets it is
normalizing our values a more common
approach to normalizing your data would
be to subtract the lowest value from all
the other values that you're sending
into the neural net and then to divide
by the highest value minus the lowest
value that sounds kind of confusing at
first if we were to take one of these
lines for example this first one scaled
down and we used it right here and the
net result of this is let's say step dot
open was 140 we're going to subtract if
138 was the lowest and then we'll divide
let's say the highest value is 147 minus
138 we would get and Wilson
tract 138 from 147 and then equals nine
and so the net result is two divided by
nine and that equals zero point two two
two two two two two two and what's
important about this is it's the end
value is between zero and one try and
rewrite the scale down and scale up
functions to incorporate the more
generalized approach which would be to
subtract the lowest value divided by the
highest - the lowest value
in our last tutorial we talked about
normalizing data and in this tutorial
we're going to write the neural net and
we're gonna put that normalized data
into it so first let's scale all of our
raw data we're gonna call this scaled
data it's not yet training data but it's
close we're gonna say raw data dot map
and we're gonna map over all those
values using our scale down function so
now our scaled data will have all of
those new values that are normalized
next what we want to do is rather than
feed in one long array of all these
objects these properties so that the
neural net memorizes this one long
pattern what the neural net to
understand smaller patterns and to
predict off of those and so how we're
going to do that is we're gonna create
finally our training data and our
training data is going to be an array of
arrays we're gonna take our scaled and
data and we're going to slice it into
chunks of five starting at the first
index and we're going to progress by
five indexes each time so that is our
training data and we can console.log it
out make sure it looks right very nice
okay so it's an array of arrays that's
an important concept okay so now that we
have our data
chunked and normalized and ready to go
into the neural net we're gonna write
our neural net so const net equals a new
brain dot the recurrent that will long
short-term memory time step that's our
neural net and we're gonna define it
with a few options now this is important
our scaled-down data has four different
properties here open high low and close
that represents one point in time or one
step through time
so our noun that is going to have an
input size of those properties being
them four properties our input size will
be four and it's very rare to deviate
from that without put size so we'll go
ahead and put an output size of four as
well and so now we wanted to find our
hidden layers and our hidden layers are
simply going to be eight neurons and
eight neurons so input size of four
hidden layers of eight and eight and in
an output size of four and now we can
learn our stock market data net dot
train training data out now we're going
to tweak our training options just a
little bit here we're gonna put our
learning rate at zero point zero zero
five and the reason we're going to do
that is so it doesn't sort of shoot past
the values that we're looking for we
want very small increments toward our
goal and the next is our error threshold
now the longer and the more data that
you end up using with your neural net
potentially longer it's going to take to
Train and so for this being just in the
web browser and we want to train to a
sufficiently good error I'm going to
turn it down to zero point zero two and
as well let's go ahead and log out our
values
let's clean this up all right
and now let's learn let's see what comes
out very cool all right so it trained
let's log out what really matters
so that's console dot log and that'll be
net dot run and let's just give it the
first item in our training data so our
training data and let's see what comes
out very cool so our net actually
learned something and returned something
now there's a problem here if we look at
our original values they're all in the
mid 140 s or so but our values here are
not they're close to is your own one so
what do we want to do there well I'll
give you a moment to think about it okay
this is where we finally use scale up
this is where we D normalize our values
here we go I went ahead and added that
as a wrapper around net run and we'll
run it again and there we go the values
that look very familiar our one 40s or
so one thing that would be really useful
is to not just look one step into the
future which is what we're doing right
here that's what net dot run would be
it's going to take all of our existing
steps and say hey this is the potential
next step what we want to do is actually
look and see what the next two or three
steps may be
in our last tutorial
the next step for stock market data and
in this tutorial we're going to predict
the next three steps that's really
interesting and cool and it's actually
quite simple so we're gonna actually
just change one little method so rather
than use net dot run I'm gonna comment
this out and I'm gonna say console dot
log we're going to do net dot forecast
and let's say we just have a couple
numbers to go on we're going to send in
our training data but we're going to
only send in a couple of steps of that
data and then we're going to say with
forecast that we like the next three
steps and it doesn't stop there it's
actually going to return an array and
before we had wrapped net run in
scale-up whereas here and not forecast
because we're getting an array rather
than an object which would be your next
step the array would be the next steps
and so we can take this and Matt to
scale up all right here we go
and there's our data that's where the
net is learned and it's its next
prediction so we've got the beginning of
one
there's our our second and three I think
the console doesn't log of reload my the
cursor but the idea is there and so as
the data
in this tutorial we are going to take a
recurrent neural network and we're going
to learn math and we're gonna do it
character by character and at first that
sounds kind of weird but you'll notice
something interesting at first with our
training data here there are no numbers
not directly these are strings even
though there are numbers inside of them
and we're gonna feed these directly into
the neural net this is where it gets
interesting especially with recurrent
neural nets so the way that a recurrent
neural networks is it has an input map
and that map is kind of like an array
and that array maps a value that is
coming into the neural net to a neuron
and it does so by index and this is how
it works
by first sitting in our training data
the training data is analyzed and we
pull out unique values like 0 the next
value being plus and the next value
being equals because 0 is repeating up
here we've already established it equals
would be the next one 0 is repeating
again and 0 and plus repeats again and
the next unique value we have is 1 and
the next item in the array and that
happens throughout our entire training
set so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 & 9 and so we
build sort of an input map and the
reason why that's important is the input
map lines up with neurons so our input
map is more or less the same size as our
input size and that's calculated
internally inside of the neural net so
that's it's important but we don't have
to think about it so much so input map
is the same size as the input size and
what that means is for each one of these
characters they get there
own neuron and so if we step through a
problem for example like a zero plus
zero equals zero to the net we feed in a
brand new array each time with that one
value activated and so our input
internally may look like this so we've
got a bunch of zeros and so the the
inputs literally look like okay so input
length equals input size so each one of
these values is sort of attached to an
input neuron and this is why that
matters
each time we feed in one of these
characters it goes all the way through
the neural net and then we can do that
over and over and over again so the math
problem zero plus zero equals one
literally looks like this to the neural
net it looks like zero plus zero and
that's the third one equals zero so that
is our first math problem sort of
internally to the neural net but it does
everything sort of automagically for us
and this is a good kind of magic it's
not the bad kind it's the kind that is
predictable so we'll go ahead and
comment that out and this out to all
right so we're ready to go ahead and
predict our numbers so this is what
happens next we're going to define our
net const net equals new brain dot or
recurrent dot along short-term memory
and we're gonna have hidden layers of 20
and we're gonna net dot train on our
training data and we are going to set
our error threshold to 0.025 and we're
gonna go ahead and log out our value all
right so we'll go ahead and learn it and
we'll see what happens very cool now a
word of caution here it did learn it but
if you crank down your error threshold
the net may be able to learn it but in
the browser it can take a long time and
a long short term memory neural net is
quite complex in contrast with our
previous neural nets there's a lot more
going on in the long short-term memory
than the others
so our net was able to learn it but of
course that's not the fun part the fun
part is actually getting to see what
comes out of the net so let's do that
net dot run and we're just going to give
it some straight-up old strings 0 plus 1
equals and we're gonna see what comes
out there but let's not stop there let's
just think of a few let's see 4.1 and
depending on the error rate to some of
these values may be a little bit
incorrect but they should be pretty
close it's quite entertaining what a
neural net can can actually give us okay
so we're gonna run these three values
and see what happens all right 0 plus 1
is 1 4 plus 1 is 5 and 2 plus 1 is 3 we
nailed it
awesome so that is recurrent neural
networks learning math now if you want
to do some bonus material light it up
with some math problems
in this tutorial we're gonna read
numbers like you would from an image and
for visual simplicity our raw data is
going to be of strings like you see here
spaces are what we don't want the neural
net to see and this asterisk is what we
do want the neural net to see now we're
gonna use this simple string and a
simple normalization function to convert
these inputs right here to zeros and
ones so let's go ahead and write that
first so we're gonna create a function
and we're gonna call it two number and
it's gonna take a character as an input
what we're going to return from this
function is if the character equals an
asterisk we're going to return a 1
otherwise we're going to return a 0
that's our character by character
normalization function now we also need
to create a function that normalizes for
the entire inputs like the entire array
that function is going to be called two
array and it's going to bring in a
string now the string needs to be a
specific size and if that string dot
length isn't seven by seven and we're
going to throw a new error string in
wrong size otherwise we're going to take
the string and we're going to split it
and then we're going to map it to number
and that'll be a return value that is
everything that we need to normalize our
input value cool so next what we want to
do is I'm going to paste in some number
data but you'll notice a number of data
isn't just 0 to 9 it's actually a string
and you can see that these functions
start to make a little bit more sense
now to array is going to take this
string in and it's going to split up
this long set of characters and it's
going to convert them to ones and zeros
so that the net can sort of understand
what is is being said here well we have
0 through 9 and each of these you can
see looks exactly like the character
it's representing let's test at least
one of these values so console that log
we're going to put nine very good we
just
that represents what the neural net is
going to speak so let's build our neural
Nets so Const net equals new brain dot
neural net work we don't have to mess
with size than this because it's a
feed-forward neural net so let's build
our training data constant training data
equals that's going to be an array of
objects that have an input and each of
those inputs are going to be one of our
values above so the first one let's just
say will be zero and the output is going
to be an object and that object is going
to be of the property that we're
classifying towards with a value of 1
very good so let's go ahead and add the
additional numbers here you see we've
got 1 2 3 all the way up to 9 and so now
all we need to do is train net doctrine
training data and we're gonna log our
results out all right let's see what
happens very cool 119 iterations Frehley
low error rate very cool but we still
haven't seen anything interesting yet
let's go ahead and actually see what the
net is outputting so net dot run to
array and we're gonna give this the
number 8 and now let's see what the
neural net outputs will say constable
result equals and we'll turn off our
logging up here because we know them
they're on that's training just fine all
right here it goes very cool now what
you'll notice here is that a output is
all of the properties that we used in
the training data they're compiled
together and the one that is most likely
has the highest value so here 8 is a
likelihood of 0.7 and that's really nice
we don't have it though in a simplified
format there is however a utility
built-in to brain that is called likely
that we can use here Const a result
equals bring that likely and we're going
to use our to array and we're going to
send our net to it and here we're going
to take this to array we're going to
give it a string very good so that's our
8 and let's console.log out the results
all right here goes
very cool we got an 8 out of her neural
net all right so that was a really
simple example and it took a lot to work
up to it because we've got a little bit
of training data there some conversion
etc but play around with this and see if
you can get some different characters to
be recognized by the neural net now a
word of caution here this method will
likely be a bit fragile in the real
world without something like
convolutions and those are coming to
brain j/s in version 2 but the thing to
note here is that the principle still
applies now there is a question to be
begged here how resilient is a neural
net why wouldn't we just use a bunch of
if statements and a bunch of loops to
build this example of an 8 if I were to
remove for example something that the
neural net sees like one of these
asterisks with the neural net still
recognize this as an eight or if I did
the same with a 2 or a 6 etc well let's
find out it still found the 8 and it's
demonstrates one of the coolest parts
about neural nets and that they are
dynamic and they're resilient and that's
why they're so popular and so amazing
and for your bonus right three examples
that still match like this eight but are
not like your training data and that
will demonstrate the resilience of the
neural net have fun
in this tutorial we're gonna write a
children's book using a recurrent neural
network and we'll start with our
training data here and if you'll go
ahead and think about pausing it here
what type of neural net that would use
based off of our previous tutorials
okay likely you arrived at a long
short-term memory recurrent neural
network we're gonna go ahead and train
on our data and we're going to give it a
few options or iterations we're going to
stop at 1500 our error threshold we're
going to stop at zero one zero one one
and we're going to log our details
alright let's see if it rains very cool
and now let's get it to output something
interesting our first line from the
training data Nets dot run is Shane
we're gonna stop there with it and jump
into the more complex line I'm gonna say
net dot run it was just based off of
these two lines let's see what the
network outlets get rid of the log very
cool so it starts out Jane saw Doug and
Jane looking at each other
oh wow and then net dot run it was love
at first sight and spot had a front row
seat it was a very special moment for
all you see the net already altered a
little bit of what was going on
what you'll find is that depending on
how you set up your neural net it can
give you some really interesting outputs
and the more data that you give it the
more interesting it's going to get so
your bonus here is to experiment with
book writing
in this tutorial we are going to learn
how to detect sentiment from text
directly well notice our training data
is a bit different than prior here we
have an array of objects whose
properties are strings rather than a
raise of numbers and bearing j s is set
up to go ahead and accept this type of
input it's not a problem so let's go
ahead and get started we'll build our
neural net constant net equals new brain
dot or recurrent dot a long short-term
memory
neural net and we'll go ahead and train
net dot trained on training data we're
gonna alter our training options we're
gonna stop at a hundred iterations our
error threshold is going to be a zero
point zero one one and we're gonna log
our stats we're gonna cut to the chase
and go ahead and output something
interesting we are going to use an input
that's not from our list above we're
just going to use something that's
similar to it so net dot run I am
unhappy go ahead and log that out let's
see what we get
very cool we got sad let's remove our
log all right now let's add an
additional item net dot run I am happy
very cool now I want to point out that
we're not training this or very long and
that the error threshold if you were to
bring that a bit down and as well
iterations it's going to be quite a bit
more stable but what you may have not
noticed is that we did not send into the
neural net values that we trained it
with and yet it was still able to
classify them as happy and sad so again
we're kind of highlighting you the
dynamic ability of the neural net and
for your bonus tweak the iterations and
threshold be careful because in the
browser you can cause it to Train
indefinitely or for a very long period
of time but add five new examples in the
training data that would be up here
then logged out for five examples that
aren't in the training data all right
have fun Yellin at the computer
to meant detection recurrent neural
network and in this tutorial we're going
to explain kind of how we did it
now if you'll recall we use both inputs
and outputs for the sentiment detection
recurrent neural network that is kind of
a new concept when talking about
recurrent neural networks because we
explain them kind of like going to the
movies now there are no inputs and
outputs with movies we're just an
observer sort of watching what happens
next
however we can bend those rules in order
to fit the paradigm of an input and an
output and I'll explain how now
previously we mentioned that a recurrent
neural network builds an input map and
that is kind of like an array and each
value in that input map corresponds to
characters that are used in the training
data that those rules apply here as well
nothing has changed the input character
1 gets its own special neuron and its
own special map its own special lookup
and as well the same is with the output
of character 2 however our input map is
not complete what is different here with
the training data is that there is an
unseen character a character that tells
the neural net to transition between an
input and an output we'll call that
character the new idea character all
right and so if we look at our training
data we have an input 1 and then we have
our new idea and then we have our output
of 2 and so if we were to look at a set
of arrays that consists of what is being
fed into the neural net they look much
like this so our input map we have three
indexes three neurons ok and the first
one is going to have a value of 1 that
first value is activated that input
character 1 that is activated here and
our value that's being sent through the
neural net next we transition to the new
idea character and so there no idea it's
a 1 the next character
is followed by two so there we have a
zero zero one so each one of these items
in the array correspond to a neuron they
correspond to our input map that
corresponds to our training data it
sounds kind of confusing at first but
what you'll get to notice with recurrent
neural networks and neural networks in
general is that they're actually quite
simple
and even the math that represents them
is quite simple there's just a lot of
it's by taking advantage of those rules
and that math we can bend those rules to
our will now for our bonus here what
would the training data look like if we
start with two and end with one so two
would be our input and our output would
be one and then as well what would this
set of arrays look like I'll go ahead
and pause it here go ahead and write
your answer and we'll compare notes
all right and so now if we're to compare
our answers they actually should look
flipped and so our training data that
has an input of 2 and an output of 1
well internally to brain J has to look
like this it'll start with a 0 0 1 0 1 0
and then in finally with a 1 0 0 now
this is all internal to brain J s this
isn't stuff that you have to learn it's
just understanding the principles behind
the neural net because again a neural
net is simple there's just a lot of it
in this tutorial we are going to use
reinforcement learning this is a really
exciting frontier of machine learning
and we're gonna use it right here you'll
notice our training data is exclusive or
right where we started originally and
half of our training data has been
commented out this is important what
we're gonna do is learn these first two
items in our training data we're gonna
test against these first two items we're
gonna look at this and next item and see
that the net really doesn't understand
it and then we're gonna learn it so
let's start by creating our neural net
constant net equals new brain dot neural
network and we had hidden layers of
three and we'll do net dot trained
that's training data we're gonna log out
our results and let's see what we get
very cool so we've learned these very
first two items let's go ahead and
remove our logging and then let's take a
look at what the net actually outputs so
net dot run and we're gonna give it an
input a zero point zero we're gonna
console.log that you're not gonna do
array dot from all right let's see what
we get very cool and that's exactly what
we were expecting however if we add one
of the examples alike one zero let's see
what we get
alright very cool and that's what we
were expecting the debt has not been yet
trained on this data and so this
illustrates why reinforcement learning
is so important and necessary our
training did it may not be available all
at once it may come over time and so we
want to make sure that our neural net
can adjust for that so let's go ahead
and adjust our training data adding one
brand new example the one zero
outputting of one and you'll get to see
how we use reinforcement learning in
this feed-forward neural net all right
so training data dot push and we're
going to give it an object it's an input
array and one zero is our input and an
output is going to be of one array
all right and then really all we have to
do is take nap train put it down here
and we can give it some titles to be
fancy console.log before reinforcements
well we'll just copy all this and then
here we'll do well say after
reinforcement all right let's see what
happens all right before we have to very
similar values and after illustrates
that our net was able to reinforce now
as a bonus go ahead and add the missing
item from our training data all right
have fun
in this tutorial we're going to build a
recommendation engine we're gonna do so
using the simplest sort of methodologies
this is one of my favorite examples
because it seems so hard when I first
started in neural nets and in fact it's
actually quite simple we're gonna start
with our training data which is color
preference and imagine that this list
was built
you just gave somebody these lists of
colors blue red black green brown and
they basically wrote a number by them
how much they liked that color so they
liked blue a lot they liked read a lot
however they don't really like black
green or brown and that's how we end up
with these numbers on both the inputs
and outputs so that's our training data
and we can learn that really quick using
a feed-forward neural net so const
annette equals new brain dot neural
network that dot train and we're gonna
have our training data go ahead and log
out our stats see what happens
cool Arnett was able to Train really
quick on that data let's turn off
logging and see what we get
console dot log or rave dot from net dot
run it will say blue one
now we're gonna duplicate this line
we're gonna put Brown alright here we go
alright so the user has a very strong
preference towards blue and not so much
towards brown we can see that here from
our output so here's the scenario over
time you go back to that original user
you show them this list and based off of
their experience things they liked
things they disliked they now have
changed what they prefer and now Brown
is one of their favorite colors so how
do we get that into a neural net why
don't you go ahead and think about that
just for a moment and pause it here
okay for us to get brown into that
training data we have to put it there so
training data done we're gonna say push
just say brown one and output
we're gonna put that one all right and
so now we have our training did it in
there so now what do we need to do to
get the net to understand what this new
training data means I'll pause it here
and let you figure it out
okay next what you want to add is net
doctrine and we're gonna give it
training data and we're gonna log out
the results again stance and console dot
log stance all right and now let's see
what happens and actually let's go ahead
and console log out our values but after
we train we'll give us a fancy title as
well so before and you'll notice that we
are actually using reinforcement
learning a bit here just very simple
it's not very complicated at all
so before preference change after
preference change let's see what happens
very cool so we scroll through our
training actually let's go ahead and
remove the logging there we know that it
logged well now let's see what happens
very cool so now before our preference
change you can see that Brown was rated
fairly low now but after our preference
change it was rated at a mediocre 0.5
now why could that be positive here and
let you think about it
okay the reason is this our training
data still has reference to when their
preference was towards zero rather than
towards one we want to ensure that we
only have their current preference so
training data not pop that's going to
remove the last item from our array so
pretend this is some sort of user
interaction or server interaction
something that happened to adjust their
preferences that gave us brand-new
training data and now we're going to
train on it again and then after that
preference change we're gonna have our
brand new updated values here we go
all right before our preference change
Brown was rated fairly low at 0.05 and
after it came out of a zero point eight
nine so this illustrates both a
reinforcement learning and also how to
build a very simple recommendation
engine now your bonus here build your
own recommendation engine what's your
favorite food where do you like to go
does that change over time has it
changed since you were a little let the
net know have fun
awesome job you got all the way through
the course I am super proud and I'm very
excited that you were able to get
through listening to me but also
building and applying and seeing these
new concepts and how they can actually
be quite simple but as we're progressing
I'd like to give you some takeaways for
this course to be able to remember and
to share with others and that is this
machine learning is moving really fast
and that is super exciting
that means it's changing and it's being
adopted we're solving problems that
we've never been able to solve before
and you have a voice in that machine
learning can change directions and a lot
of that has to do with our understanding
of how to use it we're also arriving at
simple solutions are so much more
dynamic and powerful than complex ones
when applying it so if there is a
practice that you want to see more of or
if there is something you want to change
about machine learning try and introduce
it study it prove it test it to see it
is worthwhile and not only will you
benefit machine learning for you you're
gonna help all of us to have those new
tools and capabilities so machine
learning is moving fast and you have a
voice and where it goes from this course
to I wanted really to highlight that
machine learning is actually quite
simple the terminology is behind it we
can get very lost in them but when we
arrive at the logical foundation of
machine learning it is simple there's
just a lot of it a lot of numbers a lot
of logic and I want to highlight where
you go next with this simplicity with
three illustrations and they are equals
mc-squared
an AC motor and washing your hands these
may seem comical at first but follow me
the first is equals mc-squared Albert
Einstein discovered equals mc-squared
because he reasoned on that electrons
moving around an atom would be affected
by gravity kind of like when you throw a
ball into the wind like a beach ball or
something like that a child can tell you
if you throw a beach ball into the wind
that is going to be affected by it and
that's how he reasoned on the matter so
the point is that Albert Einstein used
intuition use your intuition when you're
solving problems with machine learning
and solve for simplicity like e equals
MC squared the next illustration was
that of an AC motor now a lot of people
know that Nikola Tesla helped to build
and refine the AC motor but if you go
back further
in his career you'll arrive at that when
he was in school he was shown this
dynamo type DC motor that had these
brushes and that arced it's parked
everywhere and was really crude and
noisy and he asked his teacher why it
needed to have the brushes why I needed
to spark everywhere and his teacher was
insulted by him asking the question I
made him write an essay and it's a
really interesting story but the point
is this he asked why it was even there
and from then on he started to model his
career to build a motor that didn't have
those brushes and he arrived at the AC
induction motor and refined it and he
eventually used that same idea to help
power both Chicago and New York
simultaneously from Niagara Falls it was
a simple question a simple idea that got
him started Nikola Tesla used intuition
something wasn't right about using all
that complexity solve for simplicity use
your intuition this last illustration is
one of my favorites and it's a washing
your hands and the reason is because
it's such a simple practice most people
know washing your hands it's common
knowledge it helps you to be clean but
prior to the mid-1800s it was not in
fact in hospitals doctors would do all
kinds of weird things like perform
surgeries and then go help with births
and they were wondering why their
patients are dying left and right well
it turns out that you can awesome oh
wise theorized not only that we were
being infected by something but that we
should wash our hands to prevent it and
at first it was rejected the idea was
absurd why would you ever want to wash
your hands which to us sounds absurd but
eventually it was accepted the idea
though is that ignore civilized did not
have access to microscopes and it was
not yet discovered what a germ was
Ignazio wise they used intuition and it
was a very simple problem and he used a
very simple solution use your intuition
find those simple solutions machine
learning is being applied everywhere and
that is super exciting because there is
not an industry that is not directly or
indirectly affected by it we are solving
problems that we have never been able to
as a race that is awesome but when
you're applying machine learning use
your intuition think problems through to
the end and think about the simplicity
and
at using that over complexity now this
entire tutorials been with brain Jay s
and JavaScript and for that reason
JavaScript thanks you and what I mean by
that is until recently JavaScript really
wasn't a very serious language with
machine learning but that idea is
changing and you are in part to be
thanked for that in fact anybody who is
looking at JavaScript as a potential
solution for machine learning that is
awesome and we should spread it like
wildfire not just in JavaScript but in
every language every computer language
that is out there should have the
capability of using machine learning
because it is so amazing now I want to
take this moment to invite you over to
the machine learning movement in
JavaScript which is the BR IIM website
and as well there slack channel there
you're going to find like-minded
individuals who are not only interested
in JavaScript as a means of using
machine learning but also challenging
the ideas that are out there now and
introducing new ones I look forward to
talking with you there and there are
many others that do as well thank you as
well for letting me teach this course
teaching using the screamo platform has
been a real honor and I really do think
the encouragement of the scrim ba crew
you know who you are
for prodding me along to make this
course and I want to thank you for your
time and letting me talk about these
ideas and try to arrive at some sort of
simplicity with them and for following
the entire course all the way through to
the end I look forward to seeing what
you can build and now comes the fun part
we get to use machine learning to solve
real world problems I'll leave you to it